un mois après le début du conflit dans
le haut-karabagh les combats ne cessent
de s'intensifier entre azerbaïdjanais et
arménien on le disait un troisième
cessez le feu négocié ce week end a été
rompu quelques minutes après son
instauration ce matin à d'une autre
question ce soir arménien azerbaïdjanais
elle appelle vraiment possible là c'est
l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes avec françois
devedjian avocat bonsoir c'est vous qui
avez fait voter par le parlement la
reconnaissance du génocide arménien à
vos côtés dil badie gasimov docteur en
droit international bonsoir merci
messieurs d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france alors un troisième cessez le
feu qui n'est pas qu'ils ne respectaient
par aucun des partis notre question est
sans doute celle que beaucoup de monde
se pose les arméniens
est ce qu'ils veulent vraiment la paix
aujourd'hui françois deweille jean ah
bah oui salle et arméniens il n'y a
aucun doute sur le fait qu'ils veulent
la paix ils veulent deux choses ils
veulent la paix et la paix sur leur
terre ils sont prêts à beaucoup je pense
pour obtenir cette paix ne sont pas eux
qui ont des comptes mes clients
déclenché ce conflit et ce ne sont pas
eux qui violent le cessez le feu comme
le constate tous les journalistes
indépendants qui sont sur place et qu'on
se dit indépendant c'est évidemment ceux
qui se trouvent dans des pays où la
liberté de la presse est permise même
question pour vous d'une baby asimov les
asa les azerbaïdjanais a dopé par le
soutien turc est ce qu'ils veulent
vraiment la fin de ce conflit aussi
finalement écouté les origines et bien
sûr qu'ils veulent la fin de ce conflit
sachez que lazard veillon aujourd'hui
c'est les engagés dans une guerre ce
n'est pas par le plaisir de faire la
guerre lazare région
il faut savoir que une personne sur dix
en azerbaïdjan d'aujourd'hui à savoir un
total d'un million de personnes qui sont
chassés par leurs terres et qui à 80 des
conditions abominables
cette pierre est un vrai problème pour
les arv et jean lasar régence peut être
que que ce soit le peuple azerbaïdjanais
vous que le gouvernement hasard que ces
cas soient réglés au plus
même aujourd'hui je monsieur président
aliev
il a encore été aignan fois aujourd'hui
que le jour d'aujourd'hui si l'arménie
s'engage à libérer les sept territoires
occupés et qu'il s'engage à négocier sur
le stock de haut car à voir la région
s'engage à arrêter aujourd'hui les
opérations militaires
alors la trêve devait donc commencé ce
matin à 6 heures les deux camps ont
chacun très rapidement dénoncé une
violation grossière du cessez le feu
trêve négociée âprement à washington
après celle de moscou on disait il ya
quelques jours
s il ya une solution diplomatique
possible pour les arméniens françois
devedjian et par où cela pourrait passer
pour vous écoutez je souhaite de toute
façon qu'il y ait une solution
diplomatique
la solution diplomatique pour les
arméniens elle est relativement simple
l'artac qui est le nom arméniens du
karabagh est arménien depuis au moins le
1er siècle avant jésus-christ il l'a
toujours été
il y a eu des minorités notamment
avaient ri pendant la période soviétique
en particulier pour ne pas remonter trop
loin mais de l'ordre de 5 10 se croise
et monter jusqu'à 12 13% de la
population ce subtil attaques et toutes
les séries je reviendrai pas sur
l'histoire mais de de ce référendum
prise par la population d'arta qui
demandait 3 pour attachement à l'arménie
soit son indépendance est donc la
solution pour les arméniens de larissa
qu'elle est très simple elle est
aujourd'hui de vivre librement sur leur
terre le droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux mêmes et de permettre
effectivement il ya une partie
aujourd'hui les territoires on va dire
contesté qui sont qui ne sont pas en art
saxons larzac étant une partie de la
montagne toute la partie de la plaine
n'est pas de l'artac et les arméniens
n'ont aucune revendication sur sur ces
zones là je mettrais par exception de
couloirs de la tine qui lui est dans la
montagne est une jeune arménienne et et
voilà c'est une solution qui permettrait
à chacun de vivre chez lui
et peut-être d'apprendre à mieux se
connaître et à pouvoir avoir des
relations qu'ils soient plus des
relations de conflits d'ilva dit kasimov
comment est ce que vous vous entendez
les arguments qui vient d'être qui
viennent d'être développées par françois
deweille jean léger entend souvent
l'argument selon lequel des arméniens se
représente dans le haut-karabagh depuis
des milliers d'années alors qu'une chose
d'eux les arméniens sont arrivés au
karabagh après 1828 de la région maragha
de nizan pour moi ça ne change rien qui
soit là depuis mille ans ou dix mille
ans ou 100 ans ils sont des citoyens
azerbaïdjanais ils sont sur leurs terres
les arméniens du haut karabagh il avait
un statut d'autonomie et que
l'azerbaïdjan s'engage est prêt
aujourd'hui à leur reconnaître un statut
et messieurs cette division a parlé de
des régions contestées mais après il a
il a indiqué que l'arménie n'a aucune
revendication sur ses autres régions
autres que le rap haut karabagh
cependant ces régions sont toujours
occupés par l'arménie et que leurs
populations à savoir un million de
personnes sont chassés de ces
territoires
d'autres choses aujourd'hui le haut
karabagh n'est pas occupée par les
arméniens de vukovar le haut karabagh
est occupé par l'arménie l'état arménien
donc que l arménie mais monsieur des
visions ne l'a pas démonté l'armée
prêteront un passage sur le territoire
azerbaïdjanais vers le haut karabagh
alors il faut parce que dans cette
histoire j'ai un pays appelé difficulté
parfois parce que de dire que le
haut-karabakh les arméniens du haut
karabagh qu il revendique l'autonomie ou
leur indépendance mais ensuite en
couloir vers l'arménie
donc cela revient finalement voté kiss
et l'arménie il faut déjà dire les
choses comme elles sont et ensuite
peut-être voir comment est ce que sur
les considère avec le droit
international ou autre françois
devedjian qu'est ce que vous répondez
justement finalement les arméniens ce
n'est pas l'état d'arménie
alors deux déjà je voudrais quand même
répondre sur effectivement tout un un
débat savamment entretenu par la partie
azerbaïdjanaise sur les frontières les
frontières administratives
huot karabagh un peu comme ça pour que
les auditeurs comprennent sont des
frontières comment était à l'époque
stalinienne est en réalité la découpe
naturel de la partie arménienne est de
la partie azérie pour le dire un peu
simplement c'est la montagne et la
plaine et donc le couloir de la chine
qui fait la jonction entre le karabagh
et l'arménie c'est la montagne et c'est
naturellement une zone arménienne ça
c'était le premier point le deuxième
point sur la présence de l'arménie en
art fa jusqu'au début du mois de
septembre il y avait 150 mille habitants
haut karabagh qui étaient des habitants
locaux qui n'étaient pas des arméniens
il y à un soutien effectivement de
l'armée à ses frères de l'art par et je
pense que c'est relativement normal il
est en tout cas beaucoup moins important
que le soutien qui est apportée en
particulier militaires par la turquie à
l'azerbaïdjan et il n'y a aucune
revendication aujourd'hui de la part du
gouvernement arménien a ou de l'état
arménien en général ce qu'ils habitent
là retard la seule position que demande
l'état arménien s'est laissé les
habitants de la retape déterminer
eux-mêmes ce qu'ils veulent vivre et
j'ajouterais que on nous explique les
arméniens de l'artsakh sont des citoyens
l'azerbaïdjan est qu'ils doivent vivre
en paix sous le régime azéri quand on se
rappelle il n'y a pas si longtemps que
ça
les pogroms de bakou et deux soldats et
en 1988
là les agressions constantes depuis
c'est en 1994 par l'azerbaïdjan
on peut comprendre que les arméniens
n'ai pas spécialement envie
au delà de la situation actuelle de
vivre sous le régime de la terre médian
et je rajouterais que l'art est
aujourd'hui une démocratie ce n'est pas
le cas de l'azerbaïdjan fait une raison
supplémentaire de ne pas avoir envie de
vivre sous ce régime dit le bâti gasimov
pour répondre cette idée de référendum
finalement pour demander au peuple
karabagh de quel côté ils veulent ils
veulent vivre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ça pourrait
être une solution alors quand on parle
de référendum on parle de l'indépendance
alors que la région n'a jamais été
d'accord pour l'indépendance n'a jamais
été d'accord que son territoire soit
coupé pourrait créer un deuxième est
arménien les arméniens ils ont déterminé
leur statut ils ont un état qui
s'appelle l'arménie et tous les
arméniens vivent enfin tout part
désormais des arméniens d'arménie y
vivent dans un état indépendant
les arméniens de regrets à avoir la
norvégienne a toujours parce qu'il ya
des princes est miss 34 ans de base
selon ces principes là la position d'un
arbre genèse et la suivante
l'arménie se retire de cette région
occupée et que le statut de quart à voir
et négocier la 0région n'est prêt à
reconnaître aux habitants du haut
karabagh le plus grand statut qui
n'existe même pas dans le dans la
pratique internationale
donc il ne s'agit pas de l'indépendance
dont françois la terminer mon temps de
parole a précédé vision me répondre mais
donc il s'agit pas de référent du
deuxième monde
mais chez des visions bien de dit que
l'arménie n'a pas 30 ans de conflit
mais cependant cela n'est pas contestée
il ya quatre résolutions des nations
unies qui dit que l'arménie occupe les
territoires hasard des jeunes est
aujourd'hui aussi depuis un mois que la
guerre continue
la guerre ne continue pas pour l'instant
sur le territoire administratif du haut
karabagh certes le karabagh est bombardé
mais il n'y a pas de les attaques hasard
bejjani ne se dirige pas pour l'instant
vers le territoire du haut karabagh seat
atlas et opérations militaires
azerbaïdjanais se déroule pour l'instant
sur les autres territoires qui ne font
pas partie de haut karabagh et qui sont
occupées par l'armée
françois derec gens vous répondait alors
deux points sur le référendum et le
droit des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes
je ferai juste une comparaison un état
dont je pense qu on notera trop d'accord
pour dire que c'est une démocratie de
liberté
la france aujourd'hui en nouvelle
calédonie depuis les accords de matignon
en 1988
ap mis en place un processus d'auto
d'auto dernier d'autodétermination
pardon des peuples de nouvelle calédonie
de l'ensemble de la population belkaïd
owni qui a déjà eu tout référendum qui à
chaque fois ont dit non nous souhaitons
rester français il en est quand même
prévu un troisième puisqu'on voit clair
un dom évoluer bon plutôt vers le sens
de l'indépendance
et si c'est le terme les termes des
accords de matignon de 1988
ce troisième référendum sur 30 ans
aboutit à une majorité de pour
l'indépendance la nouvelle calédonie
sera et deviendra indépendante
voilà donc là les les habitants de
l'artac ils mentent ils chez plus ni
moins qu'un que ce même processus pas et
pour l'aspect autodétermination et droit
des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes sur
l'aspect mon contradicteur vient vient
nous expliquer que le conflit actuel ne
se déroule pas au karabagh mais en
azerbaïdjan il déroule dans la zone de
sécurité du karabagh parce que
effectivement la grande crainte est la
raison du du couloir de la team qui
relie le karabagh à à l'arménie c'est
que si le karabagh se retrouve
totalement isolé au sein de leurs deux
de l'azerbaïdjan et qu'il n'a plus de
liens avec l'arménie
c'est la fin des populations arméniennes
de dare dare tac et pardonnez moi de le
dire un peu crûment mais les populations
sur vis-à-vis des arméniens ont un très
lourd passif disait un peu plus d'un
siècle un passif génocidaire qu'il
continue à nier et la confiance de le
des populations arméniennes tout elle
soit dans le monde
vis-à-vis de la sécurité que prétend
leur apporter un dictateur comme
monsieur à lierre et plus que relatif et
se pense que ce n'est pas illégitime
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté de
débattre ce soir en direction entame
verte et france merci à vous de dival
dit gasimov merci à vous françois
deweille gens